when movie's as popular as the back to
the future trilogy come along fans
always end up wanting more you know that
new sound you're looking for
well listen to this
and while it's been more than 30 years
since the release of the 1990 smash hit
back to the future part 3. beloved actor
christopher lloyd seems game to reprise
his iconic role of eccentric inventor
doc brown in a 2015 interview to
celebrate the 30th anniversary of the
first film lloyd told the hollywood
reporter i would love to do doc again no
question but wanting to do another movie
is much easier than actually making one
of course there's the tremendous amount
of time and resources that go into any
big budget hollywood production but
there's also the very real risk that
things might not turn out as well as the
studio or the fans might hope beyond all
that however there is one more major
factor that will dictate whether lloyd
would reprise his role for a theoretical
back to the future part 4. the back to
the future trilogy tackles many themes
not the least of which is the
relationship between marty and doc brown
it's a friendship that is stronger than
ever in real life too and without
michael j fox's participation lloyd told
the hollywood reporter that he would put
the kibosh on his return for part four
in fact lloyd said he would love to see
all the creatives behind the trilogy
back for another future trip referring
to fox's 1991 parkinson's diagnosis
lloyd said i think regardless of the
parkinson's he'd probably jump on the
roll and he'd be great i can't see doing
another sequel without him i would
certainly want bob zemeckis directing it
bob gale writing it and the other
principles being involved of course
maybe it's no surprise that he'd want
fox to join him on the next adventure
considering how much they enjoy working
together in an exclusive interview with
looper lloyd looked back at his
relationship with fox it's
a thrill when we
whenever we get together
he has just such a loving
wonderful
wonderful sense of
himself in his situation in time really
he just has a perspective and a sense of
humor
about it
and a joy he
he loves being who he is lloyd also told
the hollywood reporter that they'd have
to bring back the trilogy's iconic
delorean of which lloyd said it was such
a perfect choice for the film it looks
so speedy and futuristic one thing lloyd
doesn't want to see happen though is a
full-blown reboot to the franchise he
said it's hard to replace marty michael
j fox was so wonderful in the role sadly
even if the stars were to align for
another back to the future project other
variables would have to fall into place
too most importantly according to lloyd
the fourth movie story would have to
rival that of the first three one thing
that can certainly be said for the
original trilogy is that each movie had
a genuinely original plot back to the
future saw i'm already forced to keep
the past on track after traveling back
to 1955. part two found marty and doc
having to avert to terrible future and
part three had them both travel to the
year 1885 and a total shake-up of the
franchise's sci-fi stylings they're
great stories and lloyd is well aware of
this he told the hollywood reporter it's
tough to come up with an idea that
contains the excitement to the original
three but it could be done you never
know but while a new movie might not be
on the cards just yet back to the future
fans can at least enjoy a trip down
memory lane in the spring of 2021 lloyd
joined host josh gates in the discovery
plus series expedition back to the
future over the course of four episodes
gates and lloyd hit the road to locate
the original movie's a-car the delorean
that was backed out of doc brown's
moving truck at the mall in the first
film the goal after they located is to
donate the car to the michael j fox
foundation for parkinson's research in
his interview with looper lloyd said
that he essentially reprised his role as
doc brown in the series because in real
life he and the character are
essentially one and the same so i i
wasn't doing a character most you know
i'd be myself usually when i do
something it involves
taking on another life
and uh but
what i'm taking out of this instance is
my own and so it had some intricate
areas in my head anyway to explore check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you